just four months after the last one
another series of attacks on a European
capital play most worryingly in Brussels
a city that's been the focus of intense
counter-terror activity since Paris
officials across Europe scrambled to
react to this latest outrage above
Downing Street in an act of solidarity
the Belgian flag flown at half-mast
inside a familiar response from the
Prime Minister an attack on them he said
is an attack on all of us these were
attacks in Belgium they could just be
attacks just as well be attacks in in
Britain or in France or Germany or
elsewhere in Europe and we need to stand
together against these appalling
terrorists and make sure they can never
win President Obama has continued his
historic tour of Cuba he's been
criticized for making friends with
America's old enemies while not doing
enough to tackle newer far more
dangerous ones the White House issued
these photographs of the president and
his national security adviser Susan Rice
being briefed on the attacks which he
condemned in a speech to Cubans we will
do whatever is necessary to support our
friend and Ally Belgium in bringing to
justice those who are responsible and
this is yet another reminder that the
world must unite we must be together
regardless of nationality or race or
faith in fighting against the scourge of
terrorism President Obama has insisted
despite Paris Islamic state is being
contained losing power and influence the
pictures from Brussels today suggests
otherwise on a trip to Jordan the e use
foreign policy chief federica mogherini
wasn't able to control her emotions as
she reacted to the news I will stop here
you will understand this today is a
difficulty
in Paris a city still recovering from
attacks that killed 130 last November
the French president Francois Hollande
called on all Europe to show solidarity
with Belgium this is attack en a prayer
door these attacks come after others
Paris was targeted last year in January
and November other continents have been
affected too but we are facing a global
threat which demands a global response
but there are clear limits to that
global response still despite attacks on
Europe in the heart of its cities and no
political appetite for greater military
action against Islamic state on the
ground instead governments are relying
on intelligence and security measures
which have now again been thwarted
Dominic waghorn Sky News